as a dress rehearsal ahead of next
year's presidential election
france's regional voters illustrated
just how tough that battle ahead is
going to be
both emanuel macron and marine le pen's
parties failed to show that they were
the heavy hitters but for macron's
republic
on the move party the results were
particularly
bruising even party insiders can't deny
how bad this is i'm not going to
minimize what has happened
it's a slap in the face this is a
democratic slap in the face
and it's due to a very low election
turnout
[Music]
rt doesn't condone violence but what
happened to macron's party has been
particularly brutal
in several regions that party was
eliminated from the second round of
voting
after it failed to reach the 10 percent
threshold needed
the vote even saw government ministers
being
knocked out it's something of a surprise
blow for macron as his personal
popularity
has seen a surge in recent months it
also shows that his tour de france which
just took place which was seen as him
trying to shore up the vote ahead of
these elections
didn't succeed so why has his party
failed to connect with voters it shows
it's
even he is even more much more
unpopular that it was supposed to
because
uh his results are are catastrophic
it's a vote against him for last year
a lot of miscontent uh
that was shown by the yellow vest
movement
and by the fact that the government
didn't really
react to all these signals that
situation is going
worse than worst uh and the only
way the government behave was arrogance
and you know
people don't like arrogance so they
it shows that government is complete and
macro especially is completely
disconnected with the
the whole society meanwhile record
abstention levels are sending tremors
through the political
landscape more than two in three people
didn't cast a ballot that shows people
don't believe anymore in in political
class
you had striking workers who burned
collectively their electoral
card so now you have a lot of people
uh showing they don't vote they don't
want to vote
uh they don't believe in any uh
political party
in any political leader people don't
vote
not because they are depoliticized but
because they don't believe in the
existing institutions these results were
also
disappointing for marine le pen her
party had been hoping to show that they
were
serious contenders while overall the
national rally took
just under a fifth of the votes it only
topped the polls
in one region and these results mark a
significant drop in support from 2015
the big winners from this first round of
voting
were the republican party that is not
good news for president macron
who has increasingly shifted his
politics to the right
and essentially has been basing his
strategy for re-election next year
or mopping up their voters a revival of
the republican party throws that
up in the air and shows that macon has
failed to root his
party in the french psyche while many
may see this as being a contest next
year between macron and le pen
there is always a chance an outsider
could punch
seriously above their weight one perhaps
increased by the fact
that the current president's party just
doesn't seem
to cut it with voters charla dubinsky
rt paris
you